the wait is over guys ariana grande's
highly-anticipated thank you next music
video is here and the surprise cameos
are so fast yes it is so epic we were
waiting for Ariana's full visual and
it's everything we hoped for but I
didn't know that Kris Jenner was going
to steal the show the way she did of
course you know she plays the mom and
Mean Girls original played by Amy
Poehler she was amazing and I also think
that Ari's Lava hairdo was epic I mean
we've all kind of been wondering what
does she look like without the big pony
yeah without the levity and she can rock
it she has a face for it but one thing
that really threw me off was the fact
that she walked past a bride and we
obviously know that that's a nod to her
fail engagement but I really was hoping
to see ariana grande in a wedding dress
- I wanted to see her in that Bridal
white exactly we also know that bring it
on and the clovers were a part of this
against the thank you next girls my
favorite the pregnant cheerleader who is
calling Ballinger she was so good I mean
the belly was just moving yeah she did
not hold back of course we know that
this all started when Pete Davidson and
the singer called off their engagement
only for him to joke about their split
on an SNL promo ari then famously
tweeted for somebody who claims to hate
relevancy you sure love clinging to it
ha and they next
now we have bring it on Mean Girls
Legally Blonde 13 going on 30 all
wrapped in one epic video and me and
house awesome Easter eggs revealed in
ariana grande's burn book all about
those exes they're so good so juicy guys
so juicy so in the burn book ricky has a
great dancer good times man under his
name and then there's Big Sean she wrote
so cute so sweet and get this in
parentheses she put could still get it I
could not believe that part I also was
really shocked to see that Malcolm was
not in the burn book I thought she was
gonna do a great tribute or something
but she only looked up and said you know
her line about him being an angel
another thing was was really good with
Pete where his said I love you always
huge sorry I dipped but we were kind of
digging a little deeper into the huge
part and here's what we think she's
talking about the size of his will let
you roll the clip I mean he was really
cute you know he's really cute yeah and
it was it was really big but of course
we want to know which movie recreation
you think Ariana nailed and thank you
next there are so many too that to dig
into my favorite was her Legally Blonde
moment hands down
yeah it was honestly the cutest she had
the Chihuahua I mean literally every
detail was there the orange Apple laptop
the football scene where she's lounging
on a lawn chair and we even got the
famous bend and snap
do it okay I love the Putin crime that
was my favorite part I would have loved
to see ariana grande in a white wedding
dress and veil yeah me too but we know
reportedly ariana never really got to
the wedding planning stage with Pete and
she filmed today's scenes
post-breakup so I guess it kind of makes
sense right yeah I was a little shocked
to see that we didn't have as many
cameos in the final video as we did in
the teaser we kind of got all of it on
social media so that left me a little
underwhelmed
but of course ariana grande did tease on
twitter that we may see a little bit
more from her video that not did not
make the cut in the five minute video so
I can't wait to see that I'm hoping for
bloopers I love a good gag reel
especially Kris Jenner
but anyways guys let's keep the
conversation going across social I met
Kourtney underscore teza know and I'm at
Halle underscore Steven until next time
we've got you covered